the steady claim of covet infections
driven in part by the highly contagious
delta variant and the unvaccinated is
putting a new strain on hospitals the
increase comes as a seven-day case count
stands at more than 116 thousand oregon
plans to deploy 1500 national guard
troops to hospitals to assist
overwhelmed health care workers alabama
declared a limited state of emergency to
give hospitals greater flexibility on
staffing and capacity decisions
meanwhile the centers for disease
control has approved a third booster
shot for people with compromised immune
systems michael george is here with the
latest on this michael good morning jeff
good morning first let's talk about some
good news vaccinations are up this week
suggesting the public outreach and
vaccine requirements are working and
california just became the first state
to require teachers be vaccinated or
undergo regular testing but at the same
time the kaiser family foundation
reports three out of every 10 american
adults are still unvaccinated and the
situation in many hospitals is becoming
critical
the fda yesterday took a major
precautionary step by allowing a third
vaccine dose for people with compromised
immune systems we are all very worried
about the delta variant
but that may be the least of our
problems if
if coven 19 continues
to circulate across the u.s already
there are public health emergencies
throughout the country there are no
signs that things are not going to get
worse the dire prediction comes from
franklin indiana where dr david dunkle
is ceo of johnson memorial we're full
we're on diversion again today same at
atlanta's grady memorial hospital the
city's only level one trauma center
you'll have patients waiting in the
hallway on june 20th there were seven
covid patients today
103
all icu and emergency beds are full it's
more rapid than what we saw even in the
sort of third wave of the winter of 2021
and in louisiana we need more hands so
i've gone in and done everything from
pulling meds i was giving bed baths on
sunday emptying trash cans
changing sheets we do not want a mask
mandate the noise against school safety
requirements was again loud this week
[Music]
here pro and anti-mask parents faced off
in michigan but one georgia school sent
home every fifth grader after an
outbreak
one thousand florida students were sent
home in a single county in another three
teachers died of covid within 24 hours
friday 13th has never been so
frightening even hawaii isn't able to
ward off a surge of cases it is real
it is terrifying
and tragically it's preventable
today the department of health is
reporting more people infected with
kovid 19 in hawaii
than any other day since the pandemic
began
so for now the cdc isn't recommending a
third shot for everyone just certain
people with compromised immune systems
but it should be noted that in israel
where they're also seeing a surge public
health officials are now recommending
anyone over 50 receive a third dose
elaine
michael thank you